Thank You Sara hi everyone my name is
tamas nog and I'm a BD manager for
Google Play working with our key
partners in Western Europe it's great to
be here with you at play time and to see
so many new and familiar faces after we
have been discussing how to de-risk your
game launch let's take the next step
let's think about you want to take your
game out there to the crowds and for
doing so you want to build a strong and
engaged community because only will the
community your game can last for years
and when it comes about communities
YouTube is the place to be because
YouTube well that's the biggest video
platform for games out there today we
will hear - impressive strategies from
baggage the CEO of play dynamic who will
tell us how we can get our users to keep
and share their favorite moments on
YouTube and from Mickey eliminate the
CMO of spacer games who knows everything
about working with influencers but
before letting them on stage let me give
you some more background on why YouTube
matters for your game YouTube is
essentially where you uses all whether
you do a core game a casual game a game
where they are a game with VR you will
fly in the users on YouTube you can
acquire users on YouTube and you can
speak to them again and again to ensure
that they are engaged and to put this
into perspective last year we had 507
billion views of gaming content on
YouTube alone and the good news here for
everyone in this room is this growth is
driven by mobile games in the last two
years we have been seeing an increase of
300 42% when it comes to the hours
watched of mobile gaming content so this
we become more and more relevant in
future and last but not least everything
moves towards life gaming on live
streaming we also see an increase of 512
percent year-over-year when it comes to
live gaming on YouTube so YouTube is big
YouTube is relevant and it's growing but
all of these numbers do not really help
if we do not know who is actually on the
platform we have done some research and
identified three key or
ences mum are the trendsetters those
guys are basically on YouTube to just
find out whether they should download or
pay for a game half of them are actually
waiting for new game videos to be
released so to get these trendsetters on
board
you need to have a compelling video
strategy and release videos again again
and again second we have identified that
people who love game and video culture
those users are mainly in for great
videos 80% of them just love videos
because of great soundtrack great
visuals and great story so ensure your
videos are good have a high production
quality or at least a very good story
because this way you get the game
culture lovers on board and last but not
least we identified the people who love
to reconnect and who love to share those
users basically just videos because
somebody else shared it with them and if
they're in the pub and hear about a game
62 percent of them will directly go to
YouTube to research what this game is
all about so so much for the growth of
YouTube and the size of YouTube and also
the key audiences on YouTube and you
want to get all of them but before doing
so you need to set up your game properly
for YouTube you need to integrate
mechanics which enable the users to
share their favorite moments so let me
get someone on stage who can explain
this much better than I do
the CEO of play dynamic my friend Paul
goos apparently I think explain it
better than Toby am I said quite a lofty
goal there but I'm gonna try
um I I'm going to talk about a game
called golf clash today I'm hands up
here if you played golf clash kids got a
few views that's good to hear and hands
up if you shared a video in golf clash
or some polite people saying they have
well well people do say that's what
we're gonna talk about today so um one
of these we've just heard there about um
about YouTube as a platform and about
videos generally is obviously we now
know we exist in a world where people
want to share their moments where people
want to reach out into that community
and express how they feel about a
product and those great periods of
excitement they've experienced within
that product so when it came to building
golf clash we really wants
the first time really implied emic to
embrace that and to give players an
opportunity to make this really super
easy for them and we know you know the
higher the advocates the highly engaged
players will go out of their way to
share video and they'll go out of their
way to store and share and actually
overcome some quite difficult technical
challenges but what we wanted to do was
create something that really would
appeal to the mass market in that sense
so in terms of that wise this was very
much a business goal you know we've just
been talking about de-risking our
businesses and a lot of that is focused
around those core metrics of
commercialization of engagement and
monetization of retention what we wanted
to do is also build in there another
crucial metric which we didn't really
talk about this morning is it's really
driving the organic reach getting your
users to really empower the community by
reaching out and telling about the
product so very much this was about
stimulating installs stimulating they're
attentive and engaging quality of
showing those moments to think about how
we can harness those platforms we just
heard very much about the scale of
YouTube we all know that there's a
significant scale platform and when you
think about what we're doing on we're
spending money on you a you're
essentially creating those moments we're
creating moments on platforms like
YouTube that really sell our game
quality and in the cell those key
moments what a what better way to do
that than to have a player do that for
you we all know the most powerful form
of recommendation this comes from an
individual that you are interested in or
care about have some relationship with
rather than necessarily just thinking
about you a and also we want we wanted
to make sure that those moments in the
game were the key emotional moments we
wanted to make sure that we made that
piece easy as well for the player so
those those real flag bearing moments
that product the bits that I think Yin's
referred to this morning about those
bits that make the players excited we
want to make sure that the players could
share those moments as well and also
this is very much sort of an ancillary
benefit but also you know customer
support and caring for our users
long-term is a crucial element and one
of the great side effects we found from
from our integration is it actually gave
us opportunity for a customer support to
be able to look easily at the
experiences that were players were
having in that moment so thinking about
the player goals for us we know as
players we're everyone in this room is a
player of video games I'm sure and we
all love the industry that we're in we
also love the product and we want to
share those moments you know
particularly in skill games like golf
clash is we want to share how good
we want to share with the community that
we've done something special or
something funny or something different
or something new we want to reach out to
community and share that we also want to
make sure that we can store those
moments as well that we can favorite
them you know we have a language now of
sharing in our and our global digital
economy we wanted to make sure that was
in this product so what does that look
like I mean hopefully those who played
it will recognize the UI of golf clash
so what we did is we create a system
where every single shot you ever take in
golf clash is stored for you so there's
no need for you to anticipate and and if
you think about it illogical nature of
this you know you can never anticipate
that this great moment is coming so you
can't sort of get to a place thinking
I'm gonna have an awesome game today I'm
gonna make sure I'm videoing it you know
that can't happen and it even you know
in the live environment where you're
live streaming you can't guarantee that
those moments are gonna happen so what
we wanted to do is to make it foolproof
we wanted to make sure that we were
going to store every single shot you
ever took in the game so we created and
to give it some importance we stick this
right on the main HUD of the game the
replay sat there alongside all the other
key functions of the game to say this is
something that's always gonna be
tracking your movements always been
tracking your key shots and we also then
gave you the opportunity to
automatically store things that we
thought were interesting and
automatically favorite them so we have
some logic in the game that when you do
something that we generally think is
interesting from a skill perspective
will automatically share the piece of UI
you're seeing here that says look you
know you just did something that was
pretty cool you know we know from from
the way the game is played and from our
data that the thing you just did require
quite a lot of skill so we're gonna pop
this up straightaway and say here's
something that you might be interested
in sharing you might certainly be
interested in watching it back initially
and then you maybe want to want to share
that so we have a UI here that that's
again as I say accessible from the HUD
it allows you to go through all the
shots you've taken it allows you to
replay them to yourself allows you to
rename them to give them a cool name
that might be interested as a hook when
you share that out onto YouTube and to
watch them back and share them at any
point in the journey so we allow a lot
of storage in the app for players to do
this so at any point in time in a future
date or if you're having a sort of a
trade-off with with a buddy who's shared
something interesting you think you've
got one better you can go back into your
library you can name that you can share
that out again so
really low friction on the part of the
player um you'll all be familiar with
what the Google interface looks like for
sharing but it is you know it's a very
simple and mechanic it's built into the
product you know if you're not using it
please do so we've certainly seen it
something that's been very easy for us
to integrate with obviously it's both
live and historic so um in terms of
other considerations this is just a bit
of detail I'm conscious I've got eight
minutes I think my wife said to me this
morning you've never spoke eight minutes
about anything so so I'm gonna country
to keep it pretty punchy but one thinks
we wanted to do is in recording that
video we didn't really feel that we
could just share the raw data so when
you look when we starts to do this we
look back at some of the feeds we were
creating and they were quite dull
there's quite a lot of moments in the
game and those if you played it will
recognize this where you're kind of
setting up a shot you're aiming and then
in replay that really didn't look good
so he wanted to bring certain element of
pre edit to the experience so we cut out
quite a lot of dead space and we said
this isn't interesting this isn't
something that people gonna want to
relate to when it gets out onto it to
YouTube what we also did is and this
goes back to the point I was making
about you a is we also integrated a an
intro and an end card so you know from
the perspective this is also a piece of
real estate for us you know reaching out
into that huge community that Toby talks
about to drive installs an engagement he
wants to make sure that Brandon was
there and there was a key call-to-action
so everything we stored for you also has
the intro and end card on it and we also
as I mentioned already allowed
favoriting of shots yourself so in that
little library I showed you in the UI
you can favorite a shot at any point
which puts it in a separate part of that
storage system so you can go back and
look at your favorite shots and edit
that and curate that yourself and also
as I mentioned that automatic favoriting
of shots as well to ensure that the game
is telling you that this is something
interesting this is something you should
think about sharing because you did
something special here and you know
finally that ability to store replay so
I think when I created this we said we
were storing a hundred shots which allow
you to do a bit more than that now
so what does it mean in terms of data
sand pouring grass for you but but quite
interesting I think I think what's what
you're seeing here is that these are the
share opportunities per da you so you
can see that roughly speaking were ran
about one share opportunity for every
single da you in the game now clearly
that's a in some
that's a meaningless means so some
players getting lots of share
opportunities some are getting none but
ultimately overall we're creating many
many opportunities to share that are
automated that are using the system this
is not some Lee and again I stress this
having to go away think about how
they're going to record their video
think about how they're going to share
it this is the game saying to them to
you know to one person effectively every
day here's a way you can share a video
here's interesting you can put out into
the community and what we see is that
around 15 percent of those people who
have a share opportunity go on and share
it now which is a pretty impressive
conversion rate now we all think about
conversion rates and lots of our metrics
in this world and to get 15 percent from
something that isn't initiated by you
that's initiated by the game is a pretty
powerful level of conversion and what's
interesting to us is that stayed very
consistent so you can see obviously you
know the launch spike at the beginning
but this is a game now with many
millions of dear--you
that's keeping a very stable ability to
keep converting those videos to shares
and you can see what we've also done as
well as that's that's grown consistently
as that as the games grown so many many
numbers of shares going out and keeping
that consistent conversion rate which is
of course driving engagement amongst our
existing user base but as importantly
continue to drive the organic installs
and people seeing this for the first
time with an end card you know in a
curated manner shared by somebody that
they're interested in in the community
they're interested in so overall what
we've seen so far these sort of the very
very headline metrics is we've seen now
a significant conversion of those
opportunities on mass and as I mentioned
before that 15% is increasing overall so
you're seeing a start point there and
then improving outcome and I think I'm
doing ok of time so and the result
obviously here is you know these are
these are just replays so you know close
to a hundred thousand replays ready to
the screenshot on YouTube of people that
have shared that I'm out into the
community so that's it for me I think
it's just about did in eight minutes
thanks Toby I don't know about masters
but we'll try so hi everyone I'm Mickey
I head up the marketing team at space
ape games for those of you who don't
know us we're a London
mobile gaming studio we have four live
games summer I see driver kingdoms
transformers earth was and fast lane
road to to revenge
we are as a company our mission is to
create a genre defining top game so we
actually have additional five teams
working on new titles at the moment
today I'm here to talk to you about a
really great campaign that we did for
the launch of Fastlane of rotary revenge
and through that hopefully show you how
we think about influences and why we do
what we do so we think of ourselves as a
community first developer we think that
a lot of our big brakes came from
genuinely listening to our players and
allowing them to inform how we do make
our games and how we develop our games
we found that by involving top players
and influences from the very very very
early stage of the development when I
mean early stage I mean very early in
the state and in the development the
game is not nearly as polished or
anything like that but we find that by
doing that they helped us understand
what would make the game interesting for
their communities and then they became
our ambassadors so we really kind of
realized that we're on to something some
really strong marketing tool here so we
ended up going and and using this in
every single game launch that we've had
since to give you some example four
rival kingdoms we're working on some big
innovations in build building battle
genre so we needed a live community to
feedback on everything that we were
doing we recruited about hundred top
players and gaming influences to do that
for us and they helped us really shape
the game for transformers earth was for
instance we involved some big fan sites
and some gaming influences and they
helped us do all of the onboarding
process into the game and really bridge
between those fans of the IP and the
build and battle plays your honor but it
became harder and harder to reach those
big influences and all the interactions
were becoming very much transactional
based we did a few of these for the
launch of transformers earth wars and
and actually did you know kind of paid
content for that but what we found is
when someone was making videos that they
weren't really passionate about the game
that they were promoting it had to
problems one it didn't drive any results
so it didn't really justify us doing it
again and to the community picked up on
the fact that they're not being genuine
and so they were losing credibility so
in our opinion this isn't a sustainable
way of doing things rather we think that
a content creation should be a product
of a meaningful relationship that really
offers something genuinely interesting
for the influencer without asking for
anything in return they have to work
really hard these days to keep their
channels engaged to keep their channels
growing to provide the their fans
reasons to come back again and again and
again and we have to be a lot more
creative these days and think right from
the start of things that quick that
would create that inherent interest for
them Paul was talking about watchability
but also things like integrating them
into the game offer them offering them
exclusive and unique content and things
like that
that will actually make them create
content for you but not because you gave
them a brief and you paid them you know
pay them some cash but because they're
genuinely interested and they genuinely
are excited about their involvement in
your game so how does this all come
together for for for the launch of
Fastlane we created a unique opportunity
to get to be integrated into the game as
a quest giver and give our jobs that
were based on real-life interactions and
their YouTube personalities by doing
that we ended up having 21 big youtubers
integrated into the game with over 50
million subscribers in total what we did
at launch was a week week long event
that had all of them featured they all
kind of participated in that event and
then after that we had every single
weekend an event that was in either an
individual event or a collaboration
between some youtubers and what that
resulted in is tens and tens of videos
and social posts all really promoting
promoting passionately the their
involvement in the game I've got some
examples of the best executions for you
guys here
[Music]
what's up everybody boot ramp here and
welcome back to another video in my
channel so today we're playing more fast
lane it's an absolutely insane game is
just come out from the amazing guys over
space eight games all you do is put your
finger your thumb your toes your nose
anything on the screen the game purities
are fast lane put me in the game
and it was a good time and today we're
doing something really special we're
gonna be doing some of my event now
every week that's gonna be a new job and
it's YouTube are related so your
favorite youtuber it's pretty much in
this game and I'll say the magic words
to undo the Buddha's last fun yes we've
completed the next mission the thing you
got to do here is collecting 200 chests
yes we are in there too cheeky bunker
collected some chests oh yeah look at
that guys I'm collecting all that good
stuff or if I go for something else ah
that rocket came out of nowhere son oh
yes level 37 almost level 40 and then I
can get a new car which is called The
Shining oh whoa oh did you see that
[Music]
cool thanks so really in terms of
results I think the most impressive fact
is that on at launch week this was our
second biggest marketing channel it
yielded hundreds of thousands of
installs and more than that it created
six months worth of content for us for
events in the game it drove the most
engaged players as you can see from the
d1 retention numbers this is a direct
product of that passion that came across
from the YouTuber to the community
really engaging them getting them to go
in the game check them out as quest
givers and and and engage and experience
the game for themselves they want the
biggest of spenders but that's probably
because of the age skew I think if it's
some if I summarize it all was it worth
it absolutely definitely if you've got
volumes and in mind for launch but if I
can leave you with one thing it's this
please don't take this specific example
as a template it's not a template it's
all about creating those relationships
it's all about thinking about unique and
genuine interactions with them and we
believe that we need to rethink this and
reinvent this for every single game
that's it thank you
[Applause]
you